[Musique]
c'est dans l'hémicycle du département
que s'est déroulée la finale du
championnat régional d'orthographe
organisé par le cdas centre
départemental artistique pour
l'animation et la culture des enfants
ils étaient 121 élèves du cm1 à la 3e à
faire valoir leur maîtrise de la langue
française
au milieu
un texte extrait du livre longtemps de
wilfrid bertile qui relate une enfance
réunionnaise dans le sud sauvage
intitulé puis sur le tremblay nous nous
sommes nostalgiques
du
du sud sauvage on adore le style sauvage
et des caisses qu'on a posé aussi des
questions aux enfants quelle est la
vision de livres que
vous aimez visites etc
le concept est très claire on aime bien
la région du grand brûlé
ces machines ou volt rang
quoi sabri nationaux et conseillère
départementale délégué à l'éducation
s'est prêté à l'exercice
je les trouvais c'est assez difficile
puisqu'il y avait pas mal de d'accord
grammatico et
je pense que j'avais plutôt réussi je
lui ai fait corriger vérifié par un
collègue du rectorat qui est présent et
on verra bien
pendant la correction de la dictée s'est
également tenue le concours de calcul
mental
[Musique]
les meilleurs d'entre eux ont été
récompensés espère bien briller encore
lors de la prochaine édition
[Musique]